this is a production of Cornell
University
and so what I wanted to talk about
however is what and I know that i
usually give talks about the research
that I do but I was invited by near to
talk about teaching today because I'm
teaching methodology at the Horticulture
Department and the plant physiology
course I will go a little detail there
is a course that is more less the only
physiology course in the plan area for
entirety of the university so everyone
who is doing plant sciences there and we
have quite a number like you guys here
assume quite a number of departments
from forestry all the way to to
vegetable management and so forth they
have to take this course after is very
important part of that and I have the
honor to teach these students and i will
tell you a little bit about what we did
in the last few years to try to make
this course a little bit more effective
and more effective for the students as
well as for instructors actually and
then also what we did in terms of
informal learning situations for our
students
students outside of Purdue University
and so when I started out teaching and
Purdue it was like the typical career
that each and every assistant professor
has that you get thrown in the water the
waters pretty cold and you have to swim
so nobody really instructs you how to
teach course I had the advantage that I
thought quite some courses in Germany as
well as in Arizona so a little bit of a
background in teaching everything that
is considered green so from plant
Anatomy all the way to the functional
genomics and planned but I realized
really quickly that there is always an
instructional problem or often in
structural problem that we are
encountered with if it comes to teaching
and there's usually a learning gap that
the students have because some of them
and especially in this course in do some
of them a very little background very
little knowledge that they bring with
them either from high school or from
other courses that they took in the
apartment and others are already quite
advanced so how to challenge the
students with a solid background
knowledge and still don't let the ones
who don't have this much of a knowledge
behind so what actually is the real
problem here the real problem is
certainly as you can see students they
always
it's never the instructor this is what
I've learned here and in this case the
diversity of the students certainly does
not really help to have the course and
teach the course in a very effective
manner if you just go with the
traditional methods of teaching like a
lecture three lectures a week and then
the lab there is about two hours per
week in classical plant physiology
experiments so we set out to kind of
address this learning gap that we found
in some cases at least and we try to
help the students how to learn because
in the course that I'm teaching them we
have students that come from a major
that is called horticulture landscape
and designers as you are Morris or bread
and butter major in the department and
these students have a career path that
usually leads them to the green skater
industry they maintain both courses
after their career to do so it said it's
a major that is kind of close to a
vocational education they have very
little introduction courses in the non
biology and non botany areas like
chemistry no lab experience and usually
also very little experience in in botany
courses besides the plant physiology and
then on the other hand just one example
but I could also pick the biochemistry
students that are our course or biology
students that on our course the water
culture science students also from our
department and they have already under
their belt eight courses in chemistry
biochemistry genetics and so forth and
at least three lab courses in for intro
courses in different fields of botany
such as plant physiology air plant
pathology story and in soil sciences and
so on and so forth so that simply
illustrates a little bit
the two outliers that we have here in
this population and we thought about
teaching tools and the teaching tools we
thought we should have something that is
a common point of reference for all
students in the class and you can say oh
yeah that's a textbook yeah you know I
mean for when the students always
complain that text books are expensive
and I agree with them some of them are
actually quite expensive and on the
other end you cannot guarantee that the
students have a very positive attitudes
toward reading 300 400 500 600 or 700
pages of textbook per semester so we
thought we have to find something else
that can serve this common reference
point it should also allow a teamwork
approach to solve scientific problems
very often we realized that the students
lack a lot of hands-on experience in
terms of learning I mean my it is you
learn very well in a lecture if you pay
attention you might learn even better in
a book because you can go back and forth
and you learn most if you work not with
your brain but with your hands because
somehow they are better than they're
connected with your brain than anything
else I think ears and eyes included so
the hands-on experience really gives the
students tactile experiences and haptic
experiences that really can translate
into in an experience that then also
increases their their scientific
knowledge and it should integrate
individual talents in a group and this
is something that to address is really
really not that easy because it it is
learning styles it means simply
translated learning stuff so some
stories they go into your lecture they
sit down and they get everything that
you say and they
memorize it and they can work with that
and it's great other safe and you know
your German accent I have no clue what
you're talking about fewer again you
just run around all the time and it just
makes me totally busy to even sit there
and these lectures so I'd rather sit at
home read my book and get what I need to
get and others have different other
different kinds of learning styles that
can also help them to learn the checks
the topics that are in the course so the
teaching tool should also ease
procedural questions so very often and
this is this is also acknowledging the
learning gap or the knowledge gap very
often some students know already how to
use a pressure bomb for example discuss
this point a couple minutes ago others
don't even know what a pressure pump is
and they think it has something to do
with terrorism or invade other countries
and so forth and also it should it
should not yes it should initiate
content questions so that the students
can beyond what they learn it's not the
regurgitating of knowledge that they get
from textbooks protocols or whatever but
they should start thinking about what
they do and work with that and then also
it should allow and this is maybe going
back to 2.1 the repeated viewing in
learning without instructions so that
they are kind of self-motivated and self
activated in terms of of the learning so
the objectives that we let me set out
was where the following we said basic
terminology related to lab and research
procedures should be taught with our
teaching tools single basic steps in 11
research procedures should be addressed
simply they should know what they need
it's perfect for example they should be
able if they use the tools to carry out
basic steps in lab and research most
underrated and the most important point
in any kind of teaching that at least
what I you is that students get a
positive attitude towards the course and
in my case because I like to teach
science courses that they get a positive
attitude towards the understanding of
scientific discovery and the process of
scientific discovery how do scientists
think and why is it important that
particular things need to be learned and
how do things fit together and how did
people get these ideas that they led to
the full synthetic transfer chain that I
now have to learn in the study and it's
really hard because all these particular
proteins in their legacies funky names
and it can hardly memorize them then so
students and instructors need to be able
to identify the frequency of the
teaching method I mean you can not just
change something and make something new
it's kind of spiffy and it looks nice
giving all this awesome they have to
tell you that it's awesome otherwise it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense it
should generate a lively discussion
discourse about the learning success so
the students can't think about did you
really get the point is it really better
than we had before or is it just a try
that was an error and and also the
students should achieve a certain degree
of ownership of the course and success
going back sorry going back to hear the
attitude towards the course is certainly
fueled and positively influenced by the
degree of ownership that a student has
it's not only a course that he or she
goes so but it's
course and they contribute to some
something to it and they get something
out of it and they can measure that and
they can tell you about this so this is
here for the for the teaching
researchers amongst your people I assume
most of you are from the Horticulture
Department and not doing that much in
this area but if you talk to people who
are interested in pedagogy and
developing teaching tools and dealing
with teaching every day the most
important and the most hurt term that
you will hear is assessment so you have
to create categories that allow you to
simply quantify what the change in the
student knowledge attitude and so on and
so forth is so the easiest way or the
the simplest way to do that is certainly
them to create question years to hand
them out to the students so let me fill
in then to get them back and then to
think about was that helpful that we ask
this question does this question who
this question tell us something about it
about the effect of our learning tool
and teaching tools or we have to change
that and what I show you here is only
the the first series of questions that
we ask the students after we implemented
the change in the in the teaching so we
asked for the videos that we made
because we were creating digital videos
i will show you a couple of examples of
that and we integrated the videos in
different steps and at different steps
of the of the course so i will give you
an example of a instructional video that
is teaching the students the content or
s is let's say interesting this
of the content of one particular
classical lab that they took and that
they had to go through another video is
a procedural video that explains to them
a device and in this case it's a device
that is not that easy to work with so
they should really know what's going on
because otherwise they might blow them
up they might blow themselves up and the
third was a video that is more a
narrative that that presents a project
that it would have done in an
independent research project that
integrated as part of the course so for
example and I will come back to that to
the assessment the outcomes that we
expected from the we called them video
podcasts were that we wanted the
increasing participation of the students
in creating in making these teaching
tools and we thought that this would
help to also give the students ownership
of the course so they are not only there
to be exposed to your changes and to
take what you what you create for them
but they are also involved in the entire
process of producing as well as
implementing as well as assessing the
the tools that we generated and in a lot
of assessments and when I teach that
course that plant physiology course what
I usually do is I mean I use different
tools to figure out if the students are
satisfied with how it goes and
address particular positives of
particular negative points during the
course one is the one minute SI it's
very simple you give a piece of paper
and a pencil to all of the students at
the beginning of the course they have
one minute to write the westward or a
sentence sound what they think is
positive in this course and they have
another minute to write it a buzz word
or sentence down what I think is
negative it needs to be changed in this
course then you simply collect them all
you go through all these these kind of
points that are thrown at you and then
the next in the next lecture for two
days later or so I go back and I present
them the result of this assessment and
also how I think I would be able to
address their criticisms or their needs
their their requests for changes and one
request that that I got a lot was the
traditional power point presentation has
its connoisseurs and it has its critics
and very often you hear oh yeah power
points of prefabricated and just go
through it and is I mean I I don't have
to waste my time here sitting in class I
can also sit at home and look at the
slide set that you are loading on the
website and this is certainly a valuable
point because some students we talked
about or I talked about
as before we'll have that learning style
and will be much more convenient with a
convenient learning stuff having the
powerpoint presentation at home just
looking at it and then even find with
that then the and therefore we also try
to assess can we use another kind of of
tool like a video like digital videos
for example as a replacement for a
PowerPoint presentation that is going
through the topic of a chapter for a
week or whatever and the dissemination
of the of the product of the videos and
to the scientific and the science
education community as Y as possible and
this was actually quite interesting we
thought about the case of we made these
videos and we thought they were really
cool and a lot of people told us oh wow
there we go and so we thought okay so we
need some some feedback on that and how
can we make sure that that these things
will be seen by a lot of people and
discussed by a lot of people so um we
started out to present this as
educational projects at the aspb meeting
and actually got invited to create an
educational boost at one of the HDD
so that the colleagues in the field
could see that and discuss that with us
and then we also put these videos that
we produced on YouTube and on some other
pages that are also distributing digital
content and I think attracted like two
weeks ago in total we had three videos
that we are going to get one thirty
thousand hits from all over the place
and get also responses in terms of
emails or or commenting points from from
all different kinds of people that use
these materials in different ways not
only for formal education situation like
a college class but also high school
teachers or four h FF a in similar
things here as well as internationally I
mean I was quite surprised to meet
somebody from New Zealand at the last is
be meeting and she she kind of scoop me
out and said hey I've seen your videos I
like that and I don't like that oh wow
that's amazing I mean of the methods
quite far before YouTube it's just that
maybe second more than then coming from
Peduto is recognizing and then certainly
to collect and analyze evaluations of
the podcasts in the lab classroom and
incorporate possible improvements into
the teaching technology so an ongoing
process that allows us to comment on our
own experience and also improve or or
add to what we have done there so this
is the first example it's the narrative
video and I should I should comment a
little bit on this then so what we did
after we realized that the students were
really unhappy but these classical prank
is
she laughs like you isolate the
chloroplasts and you show that they are
doing photosynthesis or isolate starch
and show enzyme activity and you have
two hours time for that which is what we
had in our course which is simply not
enough to do something sensible so you
can only create demonstration
experiments which in my mind do not
really do the job at least not
sufficiently so then we change that and
we gave the students the opportunity to
do independent research project where we
simply scrap the entire scheduling and
said okay you sit together with one of
the tas or one of the instructors and
then go through the entire project
create a hypothesis create an
experimental plan make sure that you get
all materials the literature and so on
and so forth so it was the weeks-long
several weeks long process of preparing
the experiment and then we make sure
that they had all the tools and and
facilities that they needed dooley
experiment and in the end I had to
present their findings in an oral
presentation we made a little bit a
scientific conference for the course and
each and every
each and every individual student and
the right individual protocol in terms
of in form of a scientific paper I mean
the structure of scientific papers and
so forth so what they learned was not
only to to kind of try to understand the
scientific process of thinking of
hypothesis-driven research but also how
to organize I mean as a team with each
other which is sometimes pretty hard as
well as material as well as being spiffy
enough to get the facilities that they
need reading papers discussing these
with instructors and TAS and so forth
and in many cases going out of our
department and talking to colleagues
that had the microscope that they needed
or the phone media that they needed and
the posters that they needed to do
particular things for them and help them
to do that project so what we all do in
a normal situation when we have a
research project where we need something
that you cannot do ourselves and so
these three students here thought about
an experiment that they were very
interested in them that was very applied
actually they thought about making tofu
so they made tofu the idea was not to
make hopefully idea was to try and find
if they can show transgenes that I mean
transgenic soybeans that are in the tofu
that they made so they made tofu of
transgenic and non-transgenic soybeans
and then they went out and bought tofu
from walmart and the health food store
and so on and so forth and use a pci
method pcr-based method to detect the
transgenes and all these food products
and they made a presentation of that
that they thought would help them to
explain particularly to their peers but
in addition to that to the families and
friends and outside people outside of
the classroom and what it is about what
they do because they told me very often
they get a question so what are you
doing in this client physiology course
oh I I do PCR I shoulder the egg like to
say to the resistance in the runner
Brady gene in soybean plants oh just go
do that that's a good thing I think and
that's about it but but they wanted to
have something that is a little bit more
telling and so forth they created this
video here let me see if I can start
that appropriately my sword is very
different genes are there is my soybeans
are it's going into my knee I good
enough well destroy me but exactly
there's got to be something different
between these two plants let's get back
to the lab bring down the crime scene
investigation so the plant science
investigation that they have there and
they also accumulate the role that they
have
so this a computer science students and
they interviewed for this video
we had transgenes of the transgene a
transgene again computer science
I
some resistance gene plows the foreign
fighters pretty highly likely because
ninety-five percent of the soybeans of
our own are genetically modified wait
hold of me Angie sciences we should test
your code to see if it in case gravity
you really do that this is very nice pcr
it takes 1 i'll go gene and make
multiple copies I see it
team there but you can only see it once
from a good job these bands are they
grab that gene right this birthday
activity know who else is to measure of
the iceberg jeans this length empty
because there's no router gene in plant
this last name is Carmen Angela which
doesn't image uniter this band is going
to a beam without leaves in this one is
from your tofu you can see the
multivator out that he makes sense
so we saw me he this boy be passed
through a tagine and this one nothing
great job team another piece I'm history
okay so this was this was the the first
example that I wanted to show you the
narrative important theories or whatever
would have not important there but but
what I also want to mention is it is not
only that and I will go into details in
a couple of minutes it's not only that
they did the production they did be
acting they came up with a script they
also made the animations that you have
seen em and actually the design and I
will go for this also the design of the
marketing tools that they generated was
also from them but we also had a high
school student actually who did the
musical score for us for the for the
video so everything is handmade and
everything involved the work of the
students from the very beginning all the
way through the process to the to the
last step and let me show you that
come on okay
the make sure this in a couple minutes
what I want to want to do here is go
through a very brief discourse about a
discussion that I have for the students
very often in this class so one question
that always comes back and specifically
from the students who have ideas already
about their career and the career path
is not scientific research is why do I
have to study plant physiology I mean
that's good for nothing it is
complicated and I get headaches on that
this is what I I mean I was around I
hate science and all that then but i
don't wanna mention that to too much but
i'm only little bit and so what what i
try to do here is and these are slides
that I that I developed with the
students and I do this usually at a at a
blackboard session that I simply throw
at them okay you guys tell me the 10
most pressing problems in the world
right now and i will show you how we all
saw through the horticulture is this
about the idea that we have
thank you thank you and so what always
comes up is global warming and I mean it
is it is obvious that there is a lots
there's a lot of ways to think about co2
production to think of thing about co2
sequestering with plants and so on and
so forth and how much plans have an
effect on water evaporation cloud
formation or to generation and so on and
so on it's a no-brainer in a way and the
next point that is always make certainly
biofuels and renewable resources and I
mean I think I don't have to go into
details here we all are very familiar
with these themes the next is human
health food and nutrition and especially
in a work culture Department we had food
signs as a as part of our department
until 15 years or so ago this is also
phytochemicals cancer treatments travel
medicine functional food obesity
antioxidants these are buzzwords that
they throw at me or I throw them to
address this particular point here
science education a very important point
which sometimes is forgotten but life
science education we know about STEM
education and so forth lifelong learning
this is clearly something that can be
done for the culture of plant science
and plants are interesting it's not only
animals that they have at home as pets
in Indiana they come from some of them
come from rural settings so they know
that plants grow in the soil and the
food comes from plants and so forth so
they have an idea how to deal with that
then interesting the political aspects
poverty and peace certainly people who
were employed in agriculture people who
are self subsistence and and have
vegetables for for a healthy diet they
usually have not
many reasons to to come that angry and
go for somebody else's resources so this
is also a very important point in terms
of global politics and then certainly a
question that is always coming and that
you saw also addressed in this one video
transgenic plants and foods
environmental health risks of transgenic
plants safe transgenic technology
release of transgenics and so forth this
is certainly always a question that
needs to be addressed and also we as
scientists have a very important role
there we need to really go out and be
much more pre-emptive and really go out
and tell people about that and discuss
this with people recreation and sport we
have a wonderful setting here on the
wrong Cornell and has a lot to do with
the gland science and horticulture
National Forest Park City greens golf
courses all these are aspects of this
question chemistry if we want to develop
new technologies and new materials
special oils rubbers lubricants dies and
stains that certainly will be done with
plants and the environmental questions
just one points heavy metal remediation
reforestation and so forth but there are
many many others also certainly plans
play a very important role here so you
see there is a whole hit list of the top
10 that you can make that are you
to make the students to also alert them
about the importance of plant physiology
and what they learn in this course and
let me give you a second example this
now is a procedural video this was
actually the first that was made again
by students the titleist treatment and
it explains the methodology of an
experiment that the students did in the
course it is also shorter than the first
one and it goes through the experiment
that they do so it's a pigment
extraction and an analysis of pigments
of plant pigments and again this is
produced and conceived by students in
the course for it to our experiment so
they are flowchart RHP flowers in the
greenhouse that's the original flower
color and you see we've seen things like
that my own classes because my permit
extraction of difference see the frame
in frame so they can see the procedure
itself to see the single steps so much
more clearer than in the first case
sorry for that putting them on their
face running the chromatography right
place
and then there's a second experiment
that they did sympathy aging different
engaging the same pigment extract 2
different ph steps and see the
structural changes from the molecules in
the pigment molecules that then lead to
two different coloration of the
solutions and then they they rent the
whole thing in the spectrophotometer get
a spectrum in the meantime the teals TLC
plate is running and separating the
different pigments and then isolated
from the escape from your flowers and in
some cases we then after the TLC plate
was harvested we also observed it under
UV light and found additional molecules
that do not show up in the visual light
but show up in movie so it's not always
they are what you see or there are
things there that you don't see and
again the production depended on the on
the students in the course and involved
there their work the third example even
shorter than the second so I don't want
to bore you to death with that is a more
distinct explanation it's an
instructional video yeah we also did
measurements for inspiration and water
pressure measurements for the pressure
bomb and for you guys who work with
pressure bombs already they are not that
easy to handle and you really have to
make sure that the that the students
don't try to kill themselves with it
because you work with very high pressure
and it is sometimes not that easy
so this is an instruction that they also
get but it works in it besides the
regular it's not yet whatever what be
worth 30 more trials woods before you
have the happiness to really make it
work
okay so these are the different
categories of instructional tools that
we develop advising different questions
so if you really want to construct the
students very detailed about one
particular device one particular piece
of equipment if you want to explain and
show at least one methodology or if you
want to have a narrative that is giving
background about an experiment that they
did so what you see is it is not an
instruction that comes from the from the
textbook so without the written
instruction from a textbook these videos
would not be as useful because you might
not get each and every step because some
steps you cannot depict in two and a
half minutes with various fast cuts and
so forth but these videos are thought
about a visual hook that kind of points
the students in to think about it to
prepare for the for the experiment for
the course and to be engaged and and be
attracted to it to what they are doing
so how to make videos then one is that
the students are engaged in each and
every step I set this before this here
for example is a design that I talked
about for the plant science
investigation and the students also
develop that design put it on their lab
coats and on front of the let go so they
were professional plant science
investigators hired by the FBI or
whatever I don't know and so they've
also understood that they have to create
a corporate identity to market their
products because they wanted this
product to be out there and be seen so
what we then also did is we included
these videos into
petitions for for scientific
instructional videos and they won the
first prize for that they were certainly
very enticed by that one of them
actually started studying communications
and typical munication she is now on the
track to become a science reporter or a
journalist scientific journalist I think
this is actually quite an achievement
from these reset up here so the video
production ACC is quite a complicated
process that involves many many
different steps from the the the
hardware and securing the hardware to
doing the the soft part the storyboard
to do the shooting with all its
different aspects and then the
post-production this is normally the
four steps that you need to address let
me go through some of them so the first
steps you certainly have to have some
video equipment and nowadays the video
cookin gets Cheaper by the day so it's
not that learn any more so you can even
use a very good iphone for that with a
very nice video camera and simply shoot
material that you want to use a lab
setting that is helpful and this here is
essential so we had two weekends that we
met and really developed a script for
the video so we thought about okay what
do we want to say who are the the the
target audience how do we say this how
long can it be all short doesn't have to
be is it understandable how can we test
this do we have a test audience and so
forth and so we really went through it
works we really went through it in a way
of of a a professional filmmaking
process on a very very very very very
small scale and the second step would be
then the shooting and you see here I
mean
decoration prop a mask and all different
kinds of things and then the
post-production the anything of the
video material I have to admit we have a
video artist that we enticed to help us
for that because certainly a scientist
you are not really usually very familiar
with editing and these kind of things
and also the musical scores that you
heard in these videos the students
thought that these are really important
because they not only make it a little
bit more entertaining and not that dry
and making the voice-over something from
it from professor but that gives you the
particular rhythms and when I when I
stood there and showed you the videos I
saw a couple of feet doing that and this
is exactly what i hear is so that you
you kind of get it in into a automatic
or with an automatic rhythm this that is
helping you to kind of not be not be
lost after a minute or two because the
materials too complicated that you see
in these videos so then the third steps
would be to disseminate the video and I
told you we put it on the on the web and
then also we use these videos as well as
experiments that we did for outreach
purposes so we had high school and
middle school classes that coming
through the summer we have the super
casa pooja academy of science and
agriculture as well as a FFA and 4-h the
high schoolers and wheels
coming into courses and in these courses
we use the video material as well as
simple experiments that they do because
as I said I think that working with your
hands you learn much much more than than
just working with your with your brain
another point apart from the videos and
only connected to it because you saw one
of these experiments depicted in the in
the first video on my soybeans wearing
different genes is the aspect and I want
to mention this only very briefly the
independent research projects and plant
physiology so I told you that using the
classical experiments in fact is
knowledge you're going through all
different aspects of of plant life if
you want at least the molecular plant
life and it's certainly not very
attractive and sometimes tedious
especially if you would have a lot of
time constraints like only two hours per
topic per week and so we decided as I
told you to break this up and let the
students do their own independent
research projects that are planned
together with a TA or with an instructor
and the the way I thought it would be
very effective is if we have great
students and postdocs who kind of
deliver the project out of their active
research programs this has to do
they're two different aspects that come
with that for one you have a person who
is really invested into the new to the
project because that is certainly
something maybe it's a question that the
grad student wants to address maybe as a
an experiment that he or she has to
reproduce to get the paper published or
something like this and also you have
the person with mostly the highest
expertise that you can find in this
particular area because the grad
students write off no more than there
then the advices increase it becomes of
the practical parts of experiments and
and also then the advantage in these
cases is that you have a peer-to-peer
situation that is much more clear to
appear as if it would be the professor
talking to the undergrad so having
somebody who went with the same kind of
experience just recently a year or three
years before can certainly relate to the
learning and and needs and enter the
particular requests that the students
have in totally different ways than
somebody who has been under that maybe
the nut for the last 15 years or so and
and so this is kind of a big brother big
sister approach if you want so we have
somebody not that far in advance in the
career that is able to relate in to talk
with the same
this is something that I I wanna wanna
emphasize also is very important when
you when you create these digital videos
for example other digital material that
the visual language has to be the one of
the students so that they understand
when I saw that the pavement video for
the first time it was even cut as a
faster pace I told him I have no clue
what you guys did I will never get
anything by watching this video and they
said oh no no less it's a little too
fast build make it a little slower
that's the right pace I mean it has to
come with like flashes of a couple of
seconds so they are used to watching the
YouTube and so forth videos that are all
kind in these particular ways the visual
language that somebody who grew up with
a radio game or like in white TV and the
Internet is certainly totally different
and so that needs to be addressed and
also the ability to to have music and
its core in the background that kind of
hammers in the content the content is
also important here so so what we what
we try to achieve here is to again
invest the students in what they do so
they have really something to decide
what they want to do how they want to do
it who is doing it and so forth and what
you see here is actually an experiment
that is on a on quite a scale this is
70,000 EMS lines of mace tested in dark
brown experiments on a response to a
growth inhibitor and this were eight
students worked through one semester
this this is actually here the seat
backs of the of the lines that you see
the road up here on a on a on a piece of
rope and you see these flats and flats
and flats of
to you that then had to be taken out out
of the dark and photographed and then go
through the analysis and they actually
found a couple of mutants there that
were quite helpful and presented the
data on different occasions so I want to
thank asbestos as specifically Ellen
Carla and Emily who were really driving
forces in the entire video project and
Diana Sarah was the video artist that
worked with us and Steven there worked
on them on the first set of videos and
if you want to learn more about this you
will find a website at the Horticulture
Department and and I can also if you
want give your details on that and you
can certainly always go on on YouTube
all you have to do is you have to type
in into the search in the search line
shorts pool and then if you that's very
romantic and and then and then you click
and you find all three of these videos
for you to watch again I want to make
one more remark before I finish and then
I really do finished then the shoes that
we see that is also on purpose so you
will maybe forget what I said and you
will forget where it came from and who I
am and so forth but he will say man you
know the guy with the funky shoes you
talked about these videos I remember
these shoes thank you very much
go ahead
my
my experience
that's a great question and I will
address it in two different ways first
of all no it was not supported at least
not at the start and after we won the
first award and we showed that that this
was really a very valuable way I went to
the University and ask them for funding
and then she gave me some funding for
video equipment and for some of the
materials that we needed to do the
videos and I would love to have a the
ability to hire a video editor for each
and every of the videos that we are
making so that is something that is not
possible with the funding that I got
them but most universities and I read
Cornell's is very similar this way as an
apartment of video technology computer
design or communication and so on and so
forth and very often the students and
these departments they are looking for
projects that they need to do for the
Masters or whatever and so what I'm
doing now is I'm always reaching out to
them trying to engage them at least for
the technical part because certainly
they is it seemed that the computer
science students they have no clue what
a genius and absolutely no clue what a
transgene is but they know wanna make it
anyway
I mean Karunanidhi animations here but
we already thought about and talked
about with them how it would prove that
I mean I proposed this project on a
different scale and different form also
to answer and it was funded as part of a
career grand so it will be ongoing the
next couple years them and what I but I
can't say what my experience is because
I was interested in this from kind of
early on about to the teaching and it
also doing research about teaching then
they are always institutions like center
of its structural excellence I think
there's something here that sounds the
same and things like that and if you go
there as many times as possible and try
to to participate in a benefit for me
from the office at the half there in
many cases that is quite helpful you get
always new ideas if you talk with the
researchers of teaching orbit
instructors teachers educators pedal
gorgeous and so forth and I now work
with a skeevy for underwear education on
one of these committees that are
involved in
american society of psychologists so you
kind of if you're interested in that
they are outfits that you can find where
you find yourself and your activities
address which i'm playing at these three
video touch that you know which you
regard is the most successful in of
course where is the criteria it's really
funny i would say so what do you guys
think is it the soybeans the pigment or
the pressure bomb to push for soybeans
what's your metric for success let's say
the how many people watched it or how
about how much plant physiology they
were exactly how much dragonology they
were for example how much the students
are satisfied with what they did in this
these videos so i would also say yep the
soybean video is very appealing it is it
is very entertaining and so forth but
actually the one that that resonated the
best for the students as well as the
other people decide the students is the
pressure one the video because it is it
is to the point it is clear and it is it
is no bells and whistles really explains
it is a procedure that they have to go
through that they really need to address
Master and I think that is clearly a way
that use that you have distinguished so
in your course or four different purpose
outside of your course for informal
learning situations like engaging middle
school and high school students the
soybean video would certainly engage
them attract them maybe and kind of give
them get headed that science and plant
science is something that is really
worthwhile
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu